RELEASED?
RELEASE THE MEMO.
WE WILL COVER THAT IN TONIGHT'S
BREAKING NEWS.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE TRYING TO WHIP
YOU INTO A FRENZY ABOUT A
FEAR.
AND PANIC THAT IS BASED ON LIES.
LET NOT YOUR HEART BE TROUBLED.
THE LEFT IS NOT TELLING THE
TRUTH ABOUT WHAT WILL ACTUALLY
HAPPEN IF AT MIDNIGHT THE
GOVERNMENT SHUTS DOWN.
IT NEVER REALLY SHUTS DOWN.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO TRY TO USE
THE SHUTDOWN TO BLUDGEON
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICANS POLITICALLY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE FACTS AND
THE TRUTH, THEY HAVE NOTHING TO
AND ARE PUTTING ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS BEFORE YOU THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
DACA IS IN PLACE UNTIL MARCH.
IT'S NOT URGENT.
HE AND LIBERALS OWN THIS.
FAKE NEWS, CNN, THEY ARE TAKING
THE LEAD IN LAUNCHING A FALSE
SHUTDOWN NARRATIVE TO SMEAR THE
REPUBLICANS AND THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS CLASSIC.
MICK MULVANEY, WATCH THIS.
>> HOW COULD IT BE THE SCHUMER
SHUTDOWN WHEN REPUBLICANS
CONTROL THE WHITE HOUSE, THE
HOUSE AND THE SENATE?
>> YOU KNOW THE ANSWER AS WELL
AS ANYBODY.
I HAVE TO LAUGH.
YOU KNOW AS WELL AS ANYBODY THAT
IT TAKES 60 VOTES IN THE SENATE
TO PASS A BILL.
>> I KNOW THAT.
>> YOU ONLY HAVE 51 VOTES IN THE
SENATE.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE DEMOCRAT
SUPPORT TO KEEP THE GOVERNMENT
TO FUND THE GOVERNMENT.
THAT'S THE ANSWER TO YOUR
QUESTION.
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE WHOLE
PROCESS WAS BLOWN UP BY THE
PRESIDENT'S COMMENTS.
THE FUNDING PROCESS IN 2013 WE
WERE ACCUSED BY NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER OF INSERTING A
NON-FINANCIAL ISSUE INTO THE
SPENDING PROCESS TO SHUT THE
HAPPENING TODAY?
THERE IS NO REASON YOU HAVE TO
DEAL WITH DACA THIS WEEK OVER
BEFORE THE END OF FEBRUARY.
THIS IS AN ATTEMPT BY THE SENATE
DEMOCRATS LED BY SENATOR SCHUMER
.
>> Sean: IN YOU ARE IN THE
SENATE YOU NEED 50 VOTES TO
BREAK A BILL BUSTER.
-- FILIBUSTER.
THAT'S WHY IT'S CALLED THE
SCHUMER SHUTDOWN.
IT INCLUDES FUNDING FOR THE CHIP
PROGRAM WHICH THEY SAID THEY
WANTED BADLY.
DON'T BELIEVE THAT THE DEMOCRATS
THEY WANT TO RUN ON THIS IN 2018
AND USE IT AS A POLITICAL WEAPON
FOR MID-TERM ELECTIONS.
DEMOCRATS ARE PRAYING THIS
SHUTDOWN DRAGS ON FOR AS LONG AS
POSSIBLE BECAUSE THEY WANT TO
STOP THE TRUMP ECONOMY WHICH IS
NOT GOING TO HAPPEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP REVERSED THE
ECONOMIC DECLINE WE SAW ALL 8
YEARS UNDER BARACK OBAMA AND THE
LEFT.
THEY CAN'T STAND WATCHING THIS.
THE STOCK MARKET IS AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH.
THE DOW JONES IS HAVING ITS BEST
YEAR SINCE FDR WAS PRESIDENT.
JOBS WERE CREATED AND
UNEMPLOYMENT A 17-YEAR LOW.
GOOD NEWS.
AMERICANS AND AFRICAN-AMERICANS
AND HISPANIC UNEMPLOYMENT AT AN
ALL-TIME LOW UNDER THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICY.
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE IS AT AN ALL
TIME HIGH.
FORGOTTEN MEN AND WOMEN ARE
REMEMBEREDED.
IT'S A ONE YEAR TURNAROUND AND
THE EXACT OPPOSITE WHAT HAVE WE
SAW DURING THE LAST 8 YEARS OF
OBAMA'S FAILED ECONOMY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO FOCUS ON.
THIS BE EXPOSED AS FRAUDS OVER
THE GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN,
DEMOCRATS ARE MASSIVE
HYPOCRITES.
HERE'S WHAT THEY SAID BACK IN
2013 WHEN THEY WERE TRYING TO
BLAME REPUBLICANS FOR A
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN.
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER THIS.
>> I CALL THEM LEGISLATIVE ARSON
HAFTS.
-- ARSONISTS.
THEY ARE BURNING DOWN ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT MAKE THIS COUNTRY
GREAT
>> SOMEONE GOES INTO YOUR HOUSE
AND TAKES YOUR WIFE AND CHILDREN
HOSTAGE AND SAY LET'S NEGOTIATE
OVER THE PRICE OF YOUR HOUSE.
WE COULD SAY WE ARE SHUTTING
DOWN THE GOVERNMENT UNTIL YOU
PASS IMMIGRATION REFORM.
>> I JOIN THE AMERICAN PEOPLE IN
THEIR DISGUST OF WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE SHUTDOWN OF GOVERNMENT.
IT'S AN UNTHINKABLE TACTIC TO
USE IN THE POLITICAL DEBATE.
>> Sean: THE HYPOCRISY, THAT'S
WHAT THEY ARE DOING.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE NO SHAME.
THEY HAVE NOT FIGURED OUT THAT
MOST OF WHAT THEY SAY JUST 5
YEARS AGO IS ON VIDEOTAPE.
AND DEMOCRATS HAVE ZERO
CREDIBILITY ON THE ISSUE.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT SCARE TACTIBS
SHUTDOWN WILL LEAD TO MASS
SUFFERING.
THOSE ARE ALL LIES THEY HAVE
TO SCORE CHEAP POLITICAL POINTS.
THE GOVERNMENT WILL STAY OPEN IF
THIS SHUTDOWN HAPPENS IN LESS
THAN 3 HOURS.
WATCH THIS.
>> THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION
WEAPONIZED THE SHUTDOWN IN 2013.
WHAT THEY DIDN'T TELL YOU IS
THEY DID NOT ENCOURAGE AGENCIES
TO USE CARRY-FORWARD FUNDS.
FUNDS THEY WERE SITTING ON.
NOR DID THEY ENCOURAGE AGENCIES
TO USE TRANSFER AUTHORITY.
I COULD HAVE MADE THE SHUTDOWN
IN 2013 MUCH LESS IMPACTFUL.
THE MILTARY WILL STILL GO TO
THE BORDER WILL STILL BE
PATROLLED.
THEY WON'T GET PAID.
THE POST OFFICE WILL BE OPEN AND
THE TSA WILL BE OPEN BUT THEY
WILL WORK FOR NOTHING WHICH IS
DIFFERENTLY.
WE WON'T WEAPONIZE AND TRY TO
HURT PEOPLE WHO WORK FOR THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
>> Sean: THAT'S THE TRUTH.
THE GOVERNMENT DOESN'T REALLY
SHUTDOWN.
DON'T BELIEVE THE SCARE TACTICS
BECAUSE THEY ARE NOT TRUE.
OUR BIG TOP STORY:
COMPARISONS TO KGB TACTICS.
HOW LAWMAKERS DESCRIBE THE
BIGGEST SCANDAL IN AMERICAN
130 MEMBERS WENT TO SEE THE
EXPLOSIVE CLASSIFIED MEMO THAT
SHOWED FISA ABUSES AGAINST THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN AND AN IN COMING
PRESIDENT.
ACCORDING TO SARAH, THE VAST
THE ONLY DEMOCRAT TO LOOK AT THE
4-PAGE MEMO ARE ON THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE AND ONLY
DEMOCRATS ON THE HOUSE COMMITTEE
ARE THE ONCE THAT VOTED TO KEEP
IT SECRET FROM CONGRESS.
THEY DON'T WANT YOU TO SEE IT.
WHAT ARE THE DEMOCRATS TRYING TO
COVER-UP IN THIS CASE?
WHAT ARE THEY HIDING HERE?
WHO ARE THEY PROTECTING?
WHY KEEP IT A SECRET?
POWER AND HOW THE OBAMA
INTELLIGENCE AND HOW THE CLINTON
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR PHONEY
RUSSIAN DOSSIER WAS USED TO SPY
ON THE TRUMP CAMP PAIN AND GET A
WE ASK TONIGHT YOU CALL YOUR
MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THERE IS THE NUMBER ON YOUR
RELEASE THE MEMO.
THAT'S IT.
IF YOU ARE ON TWITTER # RELEASE
THE MEMO.
I KNOW A LOT OF YOU HAVE ASKED
WHY IS IT TAKING SO LONG?
WE HAVE BEEN SINCE MARCH.
WE REPORTED FIRST THEN ABOUT
THIS ABUSE THAT THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN HAD A FISA WARRANT
SHOULD AGAINST THEM.
THAT WAS BACK IN MARCH.
WE HAVE BEEN UNPEELING THE LAYER
OF THIS ONION, THIS MASSIVE
SCANDAL.
WE GOT TO THE POINT THAT YOU
NEED TO SEE THIS INFORMATION FOR
YOURSELF.
CALL THE NUMBER ON YOUR SCREEN.
JUST RELEASE THE MEMO.
TELL THE TRUTH TO THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A FEW POWERFUL PEOPLE IN
YOU DID ABOUT WHO SHOULD BE THE
PRESIDENT.
THIS.
THE HOUSE INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE
NEEDS TO VOTE TO RELEASE THIS
INFORMATION TO THE PUBLIC.
THEY WILL SEND IT TO THE WHITE
HOUSE WHO WOULD SIGN OFF ON IT.
WITH ENOUGH PRESSURE, THIS COULD
BE DONE IN A MATTER OF DAYS.
SOURCES FAMILIAR WITH THIS MEMO
TELL US THE CONTENTS OF THIS
MEMO ARE SO SHOCKING THAT IT
WOULD LEAD TO THE FIRING OF
PEOPLE AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS OF
THE FBI AND THE DOJ.
KEEP THIS IN MIND.
EVERYTHING WE ARE TELLING YOU
TONIGHT
TONIGH
TONIGHT, IT'S ONLY A SMALL
PORTION OF WHAT WILL COME OUT
THIS YEAR.
IT WILL TAKE TIME.
WE WILL NEED YOUR PATIENCE.
THE FIRST EXPLOSIVE EVIDENCE IS
NOW AVAILABLE.
COVERING UP A BREAK IN AT THE
WATERGATE HOTEL ON GET
INFORMATION ON THE OPPOSITION
CANDIDATE.
THIS IS ABOUT THE ABUSE OF POWER
AND WEAPONIZING THE POWERS OF
INTELLIGENCE DURING AN ELECTION
YEAR AND SHREDDING OUR
CONSITUTIONAL PROTECTIONS
AGAINST UNREASONABLE SEARCH AND
SEIZURE TO STEAL AN ELECTION.
LIBERAL, A CONSERVATIVE, OR
REPUBLICAN OR DEMOCRAT, YOU NEED
TO CARE ABOUT THIS.
WE WILL LOSE OUR CONSTITUTIONAL
REPUBLIC IF WE DON'T GET TO THIS
THE BOTTOM OF THIS.
THIS WILL REMOVE ANY DOUBT THAT
SHUTDOWN IMMEDIATELY.
THESE ARE THE KEY PLAYERS IN ALL
OF THIS.
THEY ARE HIGH RANKING OBAMA FBI
AND DOJ OFFICIALS.
A LOT MORE INFORMATION THEM WILL
COME OUT IN THE NEXT COUPLE OF
WEEKS.
THE TRUMP HATING FBI AGENT PETER
STRZOK AND HIS MISTRESSES PAGE
ARE AT THE CENTER OF EVERYTHING.
THEY CALLED THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP
AN IDIOT.
LOATHSOME, F-TRUMP.
THERE ARE STILL 9600TEXT
MESSAGES WE HAVE NOT SEEN.
ONE MESSAGE GETS TO THE HEART OF
PAGE.
IT MAKES MORE SENSE KNOWING WHAT
WE KNOW.
BACK IN AUGUST, STRZOK WROTE TO
LISA PAGE.
I WANT TO BELIEVE THERE IS NO
WAY HE GETS ELECTED, BUT WE
CAN'T TAKE THAT RISK:
WE BELIEVE THAT LISA PAGE WAS
THE KEY COUNSEL FOR MCCABE.
YOU HAVE PAGE, PETER STRZOK AND
MCCABE.
WHAT IS THE INSURANCE POLICY?
IN CASE DONALD TRUMP WINS THE
THEN YOU HAVE THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY ARE TRYING TO OBTAIN A FISA
WARRANT TO SPY ON THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
SOURCES TELL US THAT THE FIRST
REQUEST FOR THE WARRANT WAS
REJECTED.
THEY SAID NO WHICH RARELY
HAPPENS.
THAT'S WHEN THE CLINTON BOUGHT
AND PAID FOR PHONEY RUSSIAN
DOSSIER WAS USED.
THEY WERE GRANTED THE FISA
WARRANT AND THAT ALLOW THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION TO TARGET AN
OPPOSING CANDIDATE IN AN
ELECTION.
THIS IS PART OF THE IMPORTANCE
THIS WAS RELEASED YESTERDAY.
HE DIDN'T VERIFY WHAT WAS IN THE
DOSSIER.
HE TRUSTED THE PERSON HE WAS
PAYING.
A BRITISH SPY STEELE.
HIS SKILLED NATURE IS WHAT?
HIS SKILL IS DEPENSION.
-- DECEPTION.
WE LEARNED THAT THE CLINTON
CAMPAIGN AND DNC KNEW HE WAS
REACHING OUT TO THE MEDIA TO GET
THEM TO RIGHT STORIES ABOUT THE
FABRICATED RUSSIAN DOSSIER.
JUST LIKE WE HAVE BEEN TELLING
YOU, CLINTON BOUGHT AND PAID FOR
A DOSSIER.
$12 MILLION.
IT WAS GOING RIGHT THROUGH ONE
LAWYER TO HER CAMPAIGN.
RIGHT THROUGH TO THE DNC.
IN IT WHAT DO WE?
RUSSIAN LIES.
ALL IN AN ATTEMPT -- HE RIGGED
THE ELECTION AGAINST BERNIE
SANDERS AND NOW TRYING TO RIG IT
AGAINST TRUMP.
THERE IS ARE SO MANY QUESTIONS.
ANDREW MCCABE, YOU NEED TO BE
FIRED AND INVESTIGATED.
SO DID THE TRUMP HATING FBI
AGENT PETER STRZOK.
FIRED AND INVESTIGATED.
HIS FBI LAWYER MISTRESSES FIRED
AND KFTHED.
-- AND INVESTIGATED.
LISA PAGE.
JAMES COMEY WHOM WE KNOW RIGGED
THE EXONERATION BEFORE THE
INVESTIGATION.
HE WILL TEACH AN ETHICAL
LEADERSHIP CLASS!
HE MAY WANT TO HIRE A LAWYER.
MAYBE AN ETHICAL ONE.
ROB ROSENSTEIN YOU NEED TO
EXPLAIN YOUR ROLE IN THIS AND
SPECIFICALLY IN YOU WERE
INVOLVED IN EXTENDING THIS FISA
WARRANT AND ROSENSTEIN NEEDS TO
BE FIRE.
ROBERT MUELLER IS CORRUPT AND
HIS INVESTIGATION NEEDS TO BE
SHUTDOWN ONCE AND FOR ALL.
IT WAS PREDICATED ON THE LIES
IT'S BIASED IN THEIR TACTICS AND
THEIR HIRING OF PEOPLE WITH
QUESTIONABLE ETHICES WHO IN THE
PAST HAVE WITHHELD EVIDENCE.
APPEALS.
YOU ONLY HIRED PEOPLE THAT
DONATED TO BARACK OBAMA, HILLARY
CLINTON AND THE DNC.
WHAT WE ARE UNCOVERING HERE IS
FAR WORSE THAN WATERGATE.
PEOPLE NEED TO BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE.
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU HAVE
CONGRESSMEN THAT SAW THE MEMO
AND THEY SAY THE MEMO IS LIKELY
AND A SHREDDING OF AMERICA'S
CONSITUTIONAL PRINCIPLES.
PEOPLE AT THE TOP.
NOT THE RANK AND FILE.
INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY THAT
PROTECT UNITED STATES EVERY DAY.
-- US EVERY DAY.
THESE WERE PEOPLE AT THE TOP.
THEY SPIED ON THE OPPOSITION
PARTY.
WE ARE ASKING YOU TO HELP US AND
DEMAND THAT THIS MEMO BE
PLACE FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
CALL THE NUMBER AT THE BOTTOM OF